elle s'est mariée à un combattant
français de l'État islamique avec qui
elle a eu deux enfants ma nièce et mon
neveu lorsque son mari est décédé dans
les combats elle a enfin pris conscience
de l'impact de son engagement sur zone
mais c'était trop tard le 28 août 2014
il est 9h je me réveille je croise ma
grande sœur Leila qui est dans le salon
elle me dit au revoir qu'elle s'en va au
marché elle n'est jamais revenue et
j'apprendrai quelques jours plus tard et
qu'elle est partie définitivement en
Syrie rejoindre daesh les rangs de
l'État islamique nous vivons dans la
commune de Roubaix l'une des villes les
plus pauvres de France je me mets à la
chercher un peu partout dans la ville
personne n'a de trace de ma sœur à cette
époque j'étais à peine âgé de 17 ans ma
sœur avait 19 ans elle aimait lire
écrire chanter elle était diplômée d'Aba
que littéraire rien dans son profil ne
pouvait prédestiner un destin dans les
rangs d'une organisation terroriste dès
le mois de juin 2014 c'est-à-dire deux
mois avant son départ j'ai pu douter son
comportement de son attitude avec la
famille avec ma maman et puis c'est
position sur les réseaux sociaux il
n'avaient plus aucun sens j'ai essayé de
la convaincre de rentrer j'ai essayé de
la convaincre de se rendre mais même se
rendre était impossible qu'elle s'est
mariée à un combattant français de
l'État islamique avec qui elle a eu deux
enfants ma nièce et mon neveu lorsque
son mari est décédé dans les combats
elle a enfin pris conscience de l'impact
de son engagement sur zone mais c'était
trop tard et moi en tant que frère moi
qui était impuissant à des milliers de
kilomètres de sa position et j'ai
toujours vécu j'ai toujours grandi avec
cette forme de responsabilité parfois
même cette forme de culpabilité comment
elle a pu aller en Syrie et pourquoi ne
reviendra-t-elle jamais je les signalé
moi-même au numéro vert stop djihadisme
au service de police pour signaler sa
radicalisation et ce numéro vert stop
djihadisme avant les attentats il
n'était pas géré directement par les
services de police du ministère de
l'Intérieur il était géré par des
bénévoles il était géré par des citoyens
lesquels étaient formés par des
associations malgré mon signalement il
n'y a pas eu de suite malheureusement en
14 à cette époque personne ne comprenait
la bascule djihadiste l'ampleur du
phénomène djihadiste et malgré nos
signalements elle a pu se rendre en
Syrie pourquoi et comment une filière
djihadiste c'est fomantée et s'est
développée non pas là-bas en Syrie mais
ici sur notre sol la France a rapatrié
15 femmes et 40 enfants des camps de
prisonniers djihadistes en Syrie ce
jeudi 20 octobre est-ce notre devoir de
les récupérer j'appelle à distinguer la
situation des enfants qui sont détenus
dans les campus en Syrie les adultes qui
eux-mêmes rappelons-le ont fait le choix
de rejoindre une organisation terroriste
pour les enfants c'est un combat que
j'assume de vouloir rapatrier plus de
300 enfants français détenus dans les
campus en Syrie pour la plupart âgés de
moins de 6 ans détenus dans des camps
sous des tentes où il fait moins de 10
degrés d'hiver et plus de 50 degrés
l'été il faut agir rapidement pour ne
pas créer une nouvelle génération
djihadiste avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
et vous comment avez-vous vécu votre
enfance à Roubaix à l'âge de 15 ans moi
qui habite à Roubaix dans un quartier
populaire ma maman a fait le choix de
m'inscrire dans un internat privé au
collège Sainte Marie tu es dans les
Flandres pour me protéger et mauvaise
fréquentation pour nous aider justement
à développer un parcours professionnel
riche ma maman et femme de ménage elle
avait peu de moyens au collège j'ai
appris
beaucoup de choses on met inculqué un
certain nombre de valeurs le respect de
l'enseignant le respect des religions on
m'a appris l'histoire de France et moi
qui n'avait absolument pas l'habitude de
découvrir ce paysage cette campagne
s'échappent ses églises j'ai retrouvé
finalement une forme de sérénité c'est à
l'internat sainte-marie-cassel ces
enseignement privé et catholique que
j'ai beaucoup plus appris sur la
religion de mes parents c'est-à-dire
l'islam que dans un quartier populaire
comme à Roubaix moi par exemple je
n'étais pas chrétien mais c'était
toujours un plaisir d'assister aux messe
ça m'a permis de m'intéresser aux autres
et ça m'a permis non pas de me
distinguer des autres mais d'avancer
avec la société
est né à Roubaix ce juriste en droit
public de 25 ans s'inquiète d'un
communautarisme qui basculerait
doucement vers l'intégrisme à Roubaix
beaucoup d'entre vous m'ont vu dans ce
reportage sur zone interdite où j'ai
essayé de dénoncer l'inaction de d'État
dans les quartiers populaires un
communautarisme de plus en plus
conséquent la montée d'une immigration
incontrôlée qui n'a rien à voir avec
l'immigration d'hier avec l'histoire de
nos parents avec l'histoire de nos
grands-parents qui eux-mêmes étaient
immigrés mais aujourd'hui je ne me
reconnais pas dans la ville dans
laquelle j'ai grandi j'habite la ville
de Roubaix une ville au 97 nationalités
une ville au passé industriel le textile
une ville d'art et d'histoire j'estime
car Roubaix nous avons accueilli toute
la misère du monde et nous avons parqué
au même endroit des populations
extrêmement fragiles des gens qui
refusent de s'assimiler qui refusent
notre culture française moi je pense que
l'assimilation ne se décrète pas elle se
désire il faut pouvoir leur donner envie
de s'assimiler à la culture française
permettre de développer davantage moyen
à la fois dans les quartiers mais aussi
dans les campagnes sur l'accès à la
culture française à la connaissance de
l'histoire le patrimoine chrétien vous
avez 12 belles églises à Roubaix mais la
moitié de ses églises sont aujourd'hui
abandonnés parce que leur rénovation
coûte beaucoup trop cher il faut
réconcilier les classes populaires par
l'affirmation de notre culture française
quand je vais chaque été dans le pays de
mes parents en Algérie les jeunes
Algériens sont fiers d'être algériens
ils vous le disent et d'ailleurs
moi-même qui suit français d'origine
algérienne on m'appelle l'immigrés alors
que quand vous êtes en France et que
quand vous dites que vous êtes fier
d'être français au pire vous êtes
fasciste au mieux vous êtes identitaire
non vous avez le droit d'être jeune
d'aimer votre pays d'aimer le drapeau
tricolore au lendemain du reportage j'ai
reçu des milliers de messages de
remerciements je n'ai pas pu prendre ce
temps pour pouvoir remercier toutes
celles et ceux qui m'ont apporté leur
soutien mais il y a aussi eu ces moments
très sombres ces menaces de violences
physiques ces menaces de mort en France
dans mon propre pays condamné à devoir
vivre à seulement 26 ans sous protection
policière de ne plus pouvoir se déplacer
seul de ne plus pouvoir aller voir des
amis de ne plus pouvoir aller au
restaurant un moment spontané toujours
tout prévoir avoir un itinéraire bis je
mesure la responsabilité du discours que
je tiens et que j'ai tenu et je l'assume
ça fait 8 ans que je subis l'islamisme
ça fait 8 ans que je subis le terrorisme
moi je veux contribuer à combattre les
filières djihadistes et les filières
terroristes Antoine de Saint-Exupéry
disait que une démocratie sans
fraternité est une imposture